Voiceover: When Richard
Serra first became interested
in bending plates of
steel over 25 years ago
he felt he'd had little
experience with large scale
curved surfaces.
Richard: I realized that there
wasn't a large vocabulary
of building with curvilinear forms
particularly in a city that's
made up of right angles.
The only curvature building I can think of
of any node in the city at that time was
Frank Lloyd Wright's Guggenheim Museum.
I wanted to build something
that would inform my experience.
If you walk around the curve
you don't know how it's going to round.
It seems continuous and never ending.
The concave side, like
a cave, reveals itself
in its entirety.
You know what the form is.
Voiceover: You'll see that
difference immediately
when you reach the opening and
step into Torqued Ellipse IV.
Richard: As you step inside,
the piece seems to have a great elasticity
as it moves around
and it either leans over your head
or leans away from you
depending on where you are.
You can see that the ellipse on the floor
is exactly the same as
the ellipse in the sky.
As the piece gets higher
it rotates in relation to itself,
but it's the same all the way up.
Initially, the way this
piece was conceived
was through a kind of misinterpretation.
I happened to be in Rome
and walked into a church
that was built in the 15th century
and I looked at the floor
and I looked at the ceiling
and I thought that the
simple ellipse on the floor
was turned in relationship
to the one overhead.
When I walked to the center of the floor
I realized that it was
just a regular ellipse
that rose like an elliptical
cylinder straight up.
What interested me was
my misinterpretation.
Voiceover: Serra became determined
to create the form he had imagined.
He went to an arrow space engineer
and asked him if it was possible
to make such a twisted or a torqued form.
Richard: He said he didn't think so.
The solution to that problem
doesn't occur in nature
and it doesn't occur in architecture.
It's a formal invention.
The first model took 3 years to be built
because we couldn't
find a computer program
or a steel mill that knew
how to build these things.
The first one we tried to
build we broke a 40 foot plate,
2 inches thick right in half.
It sounded like lightning and
I thought I'd bought the farm.
I turned completely white.
The technology has been
developed to allow one
to bend metal under heavy compression
and we used very large machines,
first used to build battleships
in the 2nd World War.
People really hadn't really
explored the potential
for what steel could be in terms of
it's variabilities and elasticity.
It's only recently been
explored by a few people.